hey guys what's up welcome to day three
of Hangout Fest we are here and there's
a lot of artists performing today that
I'm even more excited about come with me
my friends to day three of Hangout
Fest
such a fun day I made a jib with Jack
Johnson want like look shocked or do
like different emotions so you can start
with like throwing
up
yeah perfect all
right
also made a gift with Z
you you look
happy angry I'm always
angry
perfect excited I love no he was awesome
he was so sweet so nice set yeah now
we're actually heading to see Zen right
now here we
go
time for Jack
Johnson's on
the anytime
soon must
I be waiting waiting on
you st
be playing play your
fol